[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ لحظه ولاده شهر ذي القعده والقمر
يحاول بكل جديه ان يدرك الشمس وسيدركها في
صباح يوم الاحد 29 ذا القعده في تمام
الساعه السابعه وسبعه وثلاثين دقيقه وفي
مساء ذلك اليوم سيمكث القمر قرابه النص
ساعه تقريبا بعد مغيب الشمس وعلى هذا
الاساس فسيكون يوم الاثنين 19 يونيو غره
شهر ذي الحجه ويوم الثلاثه 27 يونيو وقفه
عرفه ويوم الاربعاء 28 يونيو اول ايام عيد
الاضحى المبارك عيد قيس من حب لبنى ولبنى
داء قيس والحب داء شديد واذا عادني
العوائد يوما قالت العين لا ارى
من اريد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والحد يطوف على الفصول الاربعه مره واحده
كل 33 سنه فحجم هذه السنه قير وفي عام
1450 ربيع وفي عام 1455 شتاء والقمر سيغيب
يوم عرفه في تمام الساعه 12:41 من بعد
منتصف الليل فلم ارى بدر ضاحكا قبل وجهها
ولم ترى قبلي ميتا يتكلم
[موسيقى]